If we reject the null, that means we're accepting the alternative hypothesis,
which is that there is a significant difference. That means the sample
statistic we get is very different than what we would expect for all the other
samples we could have gotten from that population. That means our sample mean
will fall within the critical region. If we just look at the positive
z-critical values, then our z-score should be greater than the z-critical
value. This means that the sample mean will lie in the critical region. And
finally, the probability of obtaining the sample mean will be less than the
alpha level. We set this alpha level as a guideline for the probability of
getting that sample statistic. And if the probability of getting that sample
statistic is low, that means there's something going on. And we have evidence
to reject the null.